my name is Angelina pereda I'm from from
Argentina
I work as a web designer and I teach web
design the National University in when
Osiris my talk was about parallax and
how to do apply parallax to our website
well the relationship between JavaScript
and parallax is that one of the many
ways of doing parallax is through Shavit
degrees and Shay query well in the web
moves really really really fast so I'm
not sure what a hell what I'm sure is it
will be awesome like html5 was
incredible and all the new CSS
properties so I guess that the future
will be bright and shiny and YouTube
well and I hope we can apply like 3d to
it make elements rotate around and all
that crazy stuff hopefully and it was
incredible because you can relate to
people like you and you can make jokes
that people understand it's like no not
in real life you go with friends and you
make a nerve show can't nobody get it so
it's awesome you get with a community
are you talk and you make friends it's
incredible I love it